let me begin first with definition of
structure and consequently function with
structure being simply the appearance of
of something
in turn that appearance
is not random it's
determined by the components the
internal components of that structure
but then also
has been shaped by the external
environment with the function
essentially just being a at all the
scales what the role of that structure
has to play
and every structure in every component
is designed to support promote and
sustain the living organism's capacity
to maintain a sustained life
structure and function are organized at
different scales and at various levels
that starts with basic components of of
life from from DNA fats lipids the
organelles that make up the components
of the cells and then every organ having
specialized function resultant from the
structure
an example would be blood vessel an
artery where an artery has an inner
lining of cells called endothelial cells
there's only one layer of those cells in
an artery and then surrounding the one
layer of endothelial cells are many
layers of smooth muscle cells
and that's related with the function of
an artery versus say a capillary which
does not contain some muscle cells only
a single lining of endothelial cells and
in turn because of that geometry and
architecture the function of a capillary
is very different from an artery though
they're both components of the
cardiovascular system
arteries are
the component of the cardiovascular
system that are transporting blood to
different organs different tissues
so they play a central role determining
where blood is going
Polaris responsibility is determining
where the contents of blood are going
where blood is transporting many factors
water red blood cells which contain
oxygen nutrients large molecules such as
fats or lipids and all the other cells
such as white blood cells and ions then
upon reaching the capillaries because of
a single layer of endothelial cells
provide the structure to allow the
contents of
blood to passively diffuse through the
cell membranes or the spaces between in
the field of cells directly into the the
surrounding tissue or organ that the
capillaries are contained in if there
was a layer of
muscle cells around then to failure
cells that would be a barrier for
transporting those contents from the
endothelial cells into the the
surrounding tissue
when one is uh Physically Active
one who is not necessarily requiring uh
utilization of every organ in the body
for example when I'm running I'm
primarily activating my muscles I'm
primarily not going to be ideally
digesting something so the arteries that
Supply oxygen to the digestive system
they shrink whereas the artery is
providing blood to the skeletal muscles
they dilate they increase in size they
change their structure to allow for more
blood to travel to
the organs that may require during
heightened level of physical activity
such as exercise and in turn
shift the
function of the cardiovascular system
based off the needs of
of the organs that they serve and
support
biological systems have had
many years
uh many many years to adapt refine and
evolve their structure
based off of the
preferred uh
function of
of that thing of that structure Nature
has does that intrinsically in terms of
evolution adaptation and has designed a
very unique structures
that can dynamically and very elegantly
adapt to the needs of whatever that
thing may be but of course there are
challenges between what what Humanity
can engineer but that's that's where
looking into mother nature and seeing
how systems are structured and how they
function and identifying
ways to reproduce us simulate that
that's really where the Next Generation
has a knowledge from from nature to
investigate and learn and consider and
think about the next generation of
Engineering Systems